bienvenue dans votre programme de
carnaval préféré pour ce numéro nous
prenons la direction du lorrain à la
rencontre de max brenner l'organisateur
de la grande parade du nord bon les gars
à tout au long du jeu max bill est en
berne depuis la fin des années 90 parce
que ça permet à nos jeunes du no1 et de
la zone de s'exprimer de manière saine
et de faire en sorte que qui sont
valorisés parce que c'est très important
d'être valorisés dans une association et
de manière générale et dans les échanges
avec des potes martiniquais que
l'extrait parce que nous sommes un
groupe quand même qui a déjà obtenu pas
mal de pays de l'appareil et de pays
ouvrir sur un de ces mondes dimanche
déjà non mais c'est pas trop l'idée
c'est de faire mon temps gris sont
fermés
y'a pas de leurs amis de show sur le
tapis rouge pour les passagers au
deuxième barrage 2 minutes sous la
douche après le briefing des groupes mac
se rejoint la ligne de départ il doit
s'assurer que le parcours est prêt il
est 14h30
la manifestation débute avec un peu de
retard
[Musique]
chaque année la manifestation prend de
l'ampleur
pour cette édition on compte pas moins
de 21 orchestre de rue cinq groupes
costumés et plus de 15000 spectateurs
[Musique]
une grande fierté c'est de voir que les
lots y moi et toute la zone non se sont
accaparés de cette manifestation
d'envergure et qui dépasse largement le
cadre d'une longue il a de la martinique
nous trouvons des groupes de guadeloupe
nous retrouvons des groupes extérieurs
qui viennent chaque année et cette
opération effectivement et l'économique
lé touristique les cultures et les
patrimoniale puisque
[Musique]
les groupes devront faire deux tours de
la ville et se produire deux minutes
devant les caméras de martinique la
première en direct sur internet
à
dans la chaleur du vide et la parade a
pris du retard
max doit accélérer le mouvement mais
quand son groupe par hill band arrive
devant lui il reprend sa casquette de
président
[Musique]
mais les deux minutes il a dit on après
y'a même pas du nord-est un événement du
nom de la martinique pourquoi et c'est
de la dépense et ce grâce aux différents
frais en sorte que les gens du nord
puisse avoir le poids des événements un
gros événement quand même et qui permet
à tout à chacun de se retrouver autour
d'une manifestation à l'esc et
touristique qui est cousu et du
patrimoine
le patrimoine est en fait partie et
quand on voit le nombre de farine il
faut ensuite sable montre que les gens
du nord où s'affairent les choses à
demain en mode inside
[Musique]